so welcome everyone thank you for
joining us at the southeast asia council
brown bag series for today's panel
discussion on resistance and literature
struggles for freedom and justice in
burma myanmar
today's uh panel will include three
speakers
who has published four novels and two
short story collections she is currently
working as a researcher on gender and
media related studies for burma-based
international ngos
in 2021 she enrolled in the phd program
in political science at mcmaster
university canada welcome
is a burma born poet literary translator
and poetry editor for mekong review
he started writing poems for sama's dot
pamphlets at the yangon institute of
technology in the 1990s
after a brush with the authorities in
1996 student protest he left burma in
1997 and has led an itinerant life ever
since cocotet has published and edited
several collections of poetry and
translations in both burmese and english
his most recent poetry con collection is
bamboo phobia from zephyr press he lives
in norwich of the uk
dr mathida is currently a visiting
research associate at the council on
southeast asian studies here at yale
and she's also the spearhead organizer
of this panel
she's published more than 25 books
including a prison memoir she is also an
alumni of writing programs of the
university of iowa brown university and
of radcliffe fellowship at harvard
university she is recently elected as
the chair of the writer and prison
committee of penn international
please join me in welcoming all three of
these panelists um so what we'll follow
from this point on for a little bit
we'll open a kind of open discussion
about the literary life of writers in
myanmar um and what i'll do is pose a
few questions to that each of the
panelists will kind of go through in a
series um to talk and reflect on some of
their experiences and then we'll share a
piece of writing from each of them and
then we'll have an open q a after that
so the first question i i want to ask um
for all three three of you is
really just to take us into the literary
world of myanmar when you discovered
yourself as a writer
how did you become a writer and what
were your influences when you were a
writer as a young
reader thinking about the literary world
who were you reading who you were
thinking about and what kind of
conditions were you facing as a writer
so i'll start with mathira
thank you thank you everybody thank you
eric
i
i think i became
i became a very very boorish voracious
reader at first so reading makes me
pretty much inspiring and then after
that i think i also want to share
some of my
thoughts opinions i and my writing
skills with the
the readers then i became a writer
that's what i'm thinking because you
know uh
reading
it's like a new world to me you know as
a teenager so
i have been reading a lot in these days
because of these very heavy censorship
the most available uh foreign literature
is sophia literature you know so
i have been pretty much uh like
that kind of the uh literature it's
already
uh having
more on the
war and peace
you became muted unfortunately
oh
sorry you said you said war and peace
and then you got muted oh
sorry uh yeah it's more more like in
that sense foreign peace or revolution
independence fighting something like
that so i
pretty much uh follow this kind of the
uh writing and the uh
literature uh more on the personal
autobiography of the independence
fighters not just from my country but
also from all over the world something
like that
and then i also
uh pretty much
reading
most of the uh all
writings too because there is almost uh
only available
uh
i i can get access to
even with that it's pretty much hot for
us so i i interested in uh also
with my own experience i'm my both of my
parents were not from
uh yangon where we live
they were from the other states where
the other ethnic minorities are and my
both of my parents are not majority they
are not mama so
i have more experience in shane's date
and moonsday and every uh summer we
visit it especially to moon's day but
sometimes to shan state so i i think
uh
because of my parents our families has
been traveling inside the country and i
noticed the general public
the
everything is not very the same
and the the lives in the other parts of
the country is very different from where
we do live that with that notion i'm
interested in
uh
explaining or telling about their
stories but at the same time i fall in
love with the uh
what should i say the
linguists itself you know the grammar
structure the vocabularies manipulation
of the vocabularies and
the nature of the burmese language
itself has very rich in ambiguous
uh vocabulary
so many uh
aspects of the linguist make me wonder
in writing
that kind of thing so i think for me
it's pretty much mixed in that sense
becoming a writer trying to
talk about what's going on on the ground
and noticing the resistance and
independence uh
fighting
of the past at the same time you know i
i
have a big notion about the
the linguist aspect of the literature
too but you know
with that one i really
uh
wrote a lot during my medical school
days
but i have experience i might save to
publish one of my short stories it took
me
12 years
to publish a novel it took me 10 years
and to publish a book it took me 30
years
so for me writing is not directly
related to publishing you know so
without expecting much
on
uh
having chance to get published
i keep writing that might be my uh
decision throughout you know i just want
to ride and i i wrote that's all so the
the
experience as a writer in nema in this
day was
you became muted again
i i didn't do anything maybe it's a
system
make me
sorry about that
yeah
so
well we'll use this as an opportunity to
turn to quartet um i hope that the
muting is not a function of
the censorship you've experienced in in
myanmar sometimes um
please tell us about your experience
entering uh to the world as a writer
uh well i have
had a somewhat uh slightly uh different
experience than matthias because well i
was a king writer
during my informative year
but i didn't know what i would like to
write but it was only at the
campus of yangon institute of technology
which you know
was and remains a hotbed for student
activism i became
a serious
poet
a semester poet we
had a cycle of students who would like
to publish our own poems not necessarily
political poems but we would like to
publish our own forms in our own way
without
having to
negotiate the repressive censorship you
know that was prevalent in the early
1990s in myanmar
so
uh
mathera says she took years for her to
get published but it was very easy for
us because it was self-published and the
pamphlets they are and they are not even
books they are not even chip books they
are really small conflicts so that's how
i became
really into poetry and and i think that
was my
first you know experience of publishing
yeah kind of self-published poet to
begin with
might i ask you
this is very interesting to hear about
the way in which you started writing
what drove you to choose poetry as your
preferred medium
what was it that attracted you to poetry
was there something going on in the
exchange of other writers in the
psalmist. world or something else that
inspired you through poetry in
particular
yes uh i was exposed to this summer's
death circle
uh most of them write
poems
and also of course if you would like to
publish as soon as that i mean no other
literary form will be
practical
because the book has to be really slim
and you know will be
uh
the pamphlet size we have to be slim and
we have to be
able to be hidden into another book
so
poetry was a practical choice and also
of course i i loved poetry and i was
inspired by contemporary poets of
myanmar like pisani
and monkey min who i translated all over
the past 10 20 years yeah
i just wanted to ask one more question
on this and we'll
move on a little bit
could you describe the conditions of
some step publishing in turn you
mentioned the size of the pamphlet
needing to be slim
i imagine that acquiring paper and
finding means to print were not as
straightforward as they might be say in
contemporary new haven where i am right
now what were some of the challenges
that you faced to actually produce some
of these pamphlets
yes uh we had had several challenges but
my times were a little easier because i
have seen some earlier you know semester
publications which were printed out of
pistoner
kind of press which is through hand
ruled and sometimes
uh typed
and hand ruled and handcuffed and
distributed but in my time there were
some computers
because we were engineering students and
some
one of my friends actually ran a
publication
uh
uh
ran a but published was a publisher so
he helped us actually made those
pamphlets
by diving into the computer and just
printing them out so it was much easier
for us but earlier earlier than our days
it was much more difficult
let's turn now to tada lay
tell us a little bit about your
experience
emerging as a writer
thank you all for giving me a chance to
share my passion story
um actually uh i would say it is because
of my mother
i became a writer
because she cultivated my reading and
writing practice since my childhood
because when i was a child
and it was around 10 years old
my mother gave me a book
which is called saladal tahari
zalada is a young girl living in
sarajevo and she wrote about her life
between the bosnian war so from the
chinese perspective
so it's like an french diary so she
became well-known after
her book released um and finally uh the
un heart her family to move to paris
so after eating her
her diary or my month told me um
if you want to go to paris like zalata
you also need to keep a diary
so i inserted a node for all my daily
life into my diary and another thing is
as my father is also a short story
writer he encouraged me to walk as a
journalist for a newspaper
so yeah so after i was graduated from
the university of foreign languages uh
i'm became a journalist
so the most challenging
theme at the time is you know
and it is uh
that we didn't have breastfeeding at the
time so that the yes censorship is the
most challenging thing so but after 2008
um we came to know that we can create
blog and website and
we can also post there for anything
where we wanted to write so around 2010
uh i published an online magazine which
is called nessu
and then in
2017 right yes uh i published my first
novel uh which is a print version so to
say frankly um yeah whenever i write
something um i think that uh i am
representing the group so that's why the
uh yeah writing is one of my favorite
things because i think that i can
represent the groups yeah and then yeah
i prefer
to read uh the books written by female
authors uh virginia wood simultaneous
and other some other burmese or female
writers as i love to know
um how women approach the society from
the female prospective to literature
that's why yeah
thank you
it's it's really interesting what you
were saying about
the moments in which you were able to
find the opportunity to start publishing
you mentioned 2010 2017
many of us here recognize the importance
of that period of change so i'm going to
circle back to you because this this is
a topic i wanted to raise with cocotet
first but then we'll come back to you i
want you to pick up on that um but the
question i have
um among scholars and observers you know
2011
is often spoken of as a kind of
watershed year as an emergence of a kind
of new set of
potential freedoms but there's also been
talk in the scholarship and among
observers that it was a kind of
ephemeral moment as well and the coup of
2021 has been a very dark
shift back to
a an alternative
more repressive approach to governance
right and so what i wanted you to
reflect upon
is if you could tell me a little bit
about
the difference as a writer what did it
feel like
um to be a writer before 2011
from 2011 to 2021 and then in today and
to kind of give us a sense of the really
dramatic differences of those conditions
um and what it meant to be a writer
during those periods and
i wanted to start with you because i
know that you've been an itinerant
writer in many ways but there was a
period in there where you had returned
to myanmar as well and i thought you
might be able to start us off on that
conversation
yes
um
before
the
decade of 2010s
situation when i was living in myanmar
before i left myanmar in the 1990s
the situation was abysmal you know
the decade started off with the 1988
nationwide uprising and the 1990
election you know where the opposition
party
national league for democracy won a
landslide so in that decade i think does
uh
in that decade dozens of well-known
writers including mathera matangi and so
many others were jailed
so the the situation was really abysmal
and to write freely means you know to
publish just illegally which we did so
that was a situation before
uh 2010s and in the 2010s
i was observing uh
the situation from a distance but three
things happened in myanmar
the first thing was introduction of the
internet or social media
and mobile mobile devices and the second
thing was the removal of much of the
censorship
in 2012 and the third one was coming of
age of the so-called digital generation
so these three things converged and
there was a sea change in the landscape
you know literally landscape in burma so
when i left
when i returned to
myanmar in 2012 after i left the country
in 1997 okay and 15 years it took me 50
15 years to return to burma and when i
returned to the country in 2012 i i
noticed there was a sea change in new
publication and literally landscape as
if the 1990s never existed
having said that of course us
some writers and poets were also jailed
in the 2010s
and even under the nld government so
today since the february coup
writers and poets continue to write but
uh as far as i know no single writer of
word has been jailed or targeted for
their writing
writers and poets have been jailed or
murdered because they were you know
leading the protest or they were part of
the protests but not not a single writer
have been jailed for their writing
um
so in my opinion it's more like
self-censorship today than you know
maybe you could return to what you were
describing about some of the the
transformation in your own writing so
how did you experience those those
periods
um yes um uh i would say uh after 2012
um we are enjoined uh the right to feed
and expressions uh yeah that earth it's
not uh
yeah and not a totally one big uh
because i would say really just a
partial freedom because uh the uruguay
uh civilian government still wanted to
push a sub censorship practice
it means that we did not need to submit
or
our writings to do their bridge press
scrutiny book bought before publication
but
we just needed to edit our writings by
ourselves
that was not to be against the existing
law but you know it's not clear um yeah
what kinds of things are supposed to be
in violation of existing laws that's why
our life is really risky i would say
so yeah so
it was like we could be taken action at
any time or prosecuted or arrested
and the national security law cyber law
or the daily communication law that's
why i'm back um i would say uh as long
as the declarators repression strategies
are getting harsh
our defensive mechanism
has also been changed to respond to
their repressions you know
what i would like to say is those
restrictions restrictions and cannot
stop our creation and our throwing ideas
that um yeah in the previous time i mean
in the haiti of president security board
the writers didn't have a chance to talk
about uh yeah human rights abuse issues
or poverty or ethnic conflict or
democracy through their writings so they
have to use some metaphors yeah
including
that oh that metaphors can
reflect what they wanted to say in some
ways when they wanted to present stories
so because at the time we had only a
premediate platform that now the
situation is changing or as we have on
that online platform as well so the way
of their repressions were changed to
digital repressions along with the
digital athletic urination um then our
resistance strategies were also changed
so um so for the time being yeah yeah
the military restricted the internet
line handled some websites and arrested
us and people for using the vpn
although we had such kind of challenges
on our site we published the online
newsletter which are more concerned with
the news articles or other creators
writings about the uh their current
revolutions and we did fundraising by
using the click to donate sites you know
it means that when we visit our website
and when we have a great number of
visitors and viewers who views
the advertising on our channels we will
end some money so we post our stories or
already books on our channels then we
invite people to come and visit to our
site um and read the story or listen to
the audiobooks by doing that we have two
benefits um
the first one is we can yeah spread what
we want to say to the audience to on the
phone and the second one is we can make
them in chem so that in camp is now
going to donations for those who join
these uh yeah civil just obvious
movement and for the ideas and also for
the human rights defenders and
protesters so that is how we resist the
repression of the military on freedom
expression biology due to the media yeah
so what you're describing now these uh
channels in which
people can read and submit a donation
for for the privilege of reading the
work
um those are ongoing at the moment right
now
in the current moment i wonder
maybe
when i'm talking to matira in a moment
if you could share a link to some of
those i think that would be lovely for
our viewers to know about um okay are
there any that are in english language
also not that it has to be um
uh no actually uh um the audio book uh
uh yes in just in burmese yeah but yeah
i would share the link yeah if you're
interested thank you that would be
wonderful yeah
so
i end with you on this topic um how did
you experience the difference between
before during and after the 2010s period
uh first of all i just want to say a
cover rider has been arrested on the day
of the coup so even though we cannot say
the reasons behind is thought to be
because of their literary walks and
literally related activities they were
arrested because it was on the very
early morning of the coup that's why you
know a lot of
there are no more arrests
or killing of the riders of poets after
the coup based on their walks but on the
day of the good we really don't know why
but there are a couple of riders like
etc you know so that that's thought to
be they are walk somehow related to the
arrest you know
so i think the before 2012 uh before the
uh censorship has been released you know
people struggle
but we need to be very careful about the
period of the censorship it's five
decades it's from 1962 to 2012.
so
for example like some topics land
confiscation or
criticisms against military it turns out
to be a terrible topic
for every people not just to
the
uh writers you know for that reason i
think the self-censorship is
it's not being noticed as
self-censorship it's like a very
standard normal you know practice you
know people that the writers the poets
might write about something they might
be criticised criticized they might be
pointed out of the bribery or corruption
etc but they never ever think so much
harsh
criticisms against the military
because you know it's it's like
for them it is the normal standard not
not go beyond this line so
it is of course it's a kind of the um
unnoticed self-censorship but at the
same time you know the kind of the beer
censorship is more on the racial or
religious sensitivity you know so it's
the writers there not to write something
racially or religiously sensitive topics
because there will be no censorship from
the state but from the peer groups you
know so you know
they might give so much pressure that's
why not many riders are
uh willing to process this line too
something like that so i think
uh after the 2012 relaxation of the
censorship ending the uh press scrutiny
board
we do have much more chance
to be independent to be free but it is
it's also depending on the either peer
censorship or the
self-censorship plus
there are still so many laws existing
are pretty much prohibiting the freedom
expression you know that's we have been
uh
working on but good thing is after 2012
because of the freedom of association
law of freedom association x there are
so many
uh new organizations new institution has
been game up for example like pam yama
you know so pentium
up in 2013 and then we have been
uh working mainly focused on the freedom
expression not on the literature but we
did have a survey in 2018
and it's for a decade
from 2008 to 2018 we have been reading
more than 3 000 short stories published
in three well-known literary magazines
to find
uh how much the myanmar literature is
inclusive in terms of gender inclusive
ethnicity in terms of the uh demography
something like that and also we have
been uh surveying about what's the uh
difference between the the topics
choosing or the
uh for the the these your stories what
we found it out is in terms of topics
it's not much change before the
censorship and after the censorship
that's me you know a couple of new
topics are becoming more
presentable at the literary magazines
for example like love stories of the
lgbtq community something like that and
then there a lot of the uh topics like
bribery and corruption
in the past you know but not many
finding uh
writing about the land confiscation by
army or the other uh sufferings in the
ethnic groups you know that's i think
the education system itself it's
pretty much yeah the the official
language is by me so that's why the
language plays a role that's why not
many
uh ethnic minorities becoming the
writers you know if they become the
writers they cannot use their own uh
mother tongue
the only the burmese language is the
medium
for us you know so that's why i think
the
uh when we talk about this
it's
like uh not very positive
in terms of freedom after the censorship
has terminated during the energy
government but
uh i have been watching some movie clips
in the past before the 2020
general election and it's that that
movie eclipse is the kind of the
documentary interviewing
uh general public in so many different
cities inside the country and a lot of
general public
both men and women
layman and the intellectuals they
mentioned that during this the last five
years they feel pretty safe safer to
criticize their own elected mbs and the
regional government's member cabinet
members something like that so maybe the
incidence of the number of people
arrested because of the spreads freely
it's a little bit
higher during the last five years
compared to the udain government but
the
uh we don't
really have that kind of the details of
it but it's thought to be you know more
people dare enough to
uh practice their freedom of expressions
compared to the things government that's
also we need to recognize so that's why
i think the whole picture is pretty much
complicated i cannot say uh
black and white in that sense you know
so
i think a good thing is the there are a
couple of the uh
writers based on literature based uh
organizations like pam myanmar is more
focused on uh freelance expression but
the other organization focused mainly on
uh writers and threats there are so many
came up before the coup yeah
thank you so much for sharing this um
at this moment before we turn um to open
up a more open discussion
i want to invite each of you to share a
piece of your writing with the group
a lot of us are really eager to hear
some of your work
so i've asked you to choose a short
passage just to give us a taste if you
can just tell us where it's
from um
which
why you chose the piece and then just
read it to us um i think we will start
with cocotet
then we'll turn to tada
and then mata at the end and then i'll
ask all of you to reflect a little bit
on each other's writing for a moment and
then we will open it up to a group
discussion with the audience as well for
question and answer um so cocotet if you
could start that'd be wonderful
uh thank you eric um i would like to
read um
a poem from this collection uh bamboo
phobia
and this collection was written before
2021 actually uh and
and
was supposed to be published before that
but then there was some delayed and it's
just out
so i'm going to read a poem called
celebrations
and
from this bombophobia
celebrations
over here we celebrate
absolutely
everything
every single day
every day is someone's birthday or
funeral
every other day
is an anniversary
of a massacre
or
wedding
we celebrate every week
when we delouse ourselves by rubbing our
shivan heads with lime
every three months
we deworm our stomachs with papaya seeds
we celebrate the spiritual power of our
polluted rivers
we celebrate plastic in our air
we celebrate the lives of spiders by
frying them for food
we celebrate snakes by skinning them
into jerky
sex
real or imagined it's the celebration of
our bodies arousal
orgasm is a celebration of bodies
contented closure
we celebrate
celibacy we celebrate and are humbled
when rapists apologize
we feast with plenty of iraq when a
mother manages to rent a womb
or sell a child
on the occasions of the funerals of
poets
who died from excessive drinking
we toast rice wine over their graves and
get best drunk
when there is nothing to celebrate
we celebrate for nothing
with nothing
all day long
every single day of the year we smile
and say to each other
how are you today have you eaten
and go on eba sleep well before bed
come morning we say
comments
have you eaten to celebrate the day
for
we are still
here
thank you
thank you
um
would you like to share a passage with
us
yes uh i would like to share some pieces
from my earth uh short story the heat of
lifter
because uh for me i am personally more
interested in telling the way or
survival of people um among the chaos
conditions
conditions
because i would like to empower and
increase their resistance
while we are resisting the repressions
so that's why in my short story in the
heat of laughter
i wrote about the sense of humor of
burmese people even in the worst
situation because uh you know uh it is
easy to make as a set of abscess uh as
our war
is full of chaos things however it's not
easy to make a smile so if we can
overcome such a bitterness and can make
an ironing towards those chaos i would
say it's a kind of something that we are
free from
uh or anxieties and i think that the
feeling of our spirits are reached to
the
extreme part that's why i would like to
highlight the sense of humor of violent
people in my story
so let me read some pieces
okay um
there is the main character cho chong
how he is optimistic about the current
situation
so jojo was lucky
he was taken near the start of the
protest
later the monsters were let loose at
night
crimeans roamed the streets
houses were set on fires
curfews were imposed
each day was worse than they went before
and all i could do was crying cuz and
clicked my turn in bitterness
jojo never changed
after our leaders were taken we merged
in protest for miles across us across
the city
my belly is too fetched anyway it's
about time i got some exercise after
facebook and other sites were blog
we all turned to vpns and secure
messaging apps
before i before i didn't know anything
about this technology now i'm like an
expert
after the state media announced a new
route of rule rules and regulations we
could be arrested for any little thing
i'm thinking of becoming a lawyer with
all the news laws i'm learning about
after the internet was cut between 1am
and 9am every night we went back to the
wall
good now i won't stay at so late
watching video
i can get back to my normal sleep
routine
after civilian was changed beaten and
shot shot we built defense walls across
the street
if there is a game we have level at this
is how to earlier optimistic about the
current situation
with her with his sense of humor but
here i forgot to mention one thing there
is one the military was shot there again
at midnight in yangon last year february
you know and how our people respond to
those gun shots was really amazing
at the time the military shot again as
to threaten and to make people frighten
while they were sleeping
that at the time we turned off the light
and then every time we heard the gun
shot we shouted happy new year
you know so our voice yelling happy new
year usually uh covered again short that
is uh one of the ways we responded to
the military threat
and i feel there is truly unique you
know
but i
forgot to include that one in my story
but other ways for resistance are
mentioned
thank you um
would you like to share a passage
yes this piece i was
i wrote this piece after the suffering
revolution and i think this will be a
good one to choose but i couldn't read
it is so quite long so i
this is the story called living the
horror
but in this piece i make the writer
looking for a piece of writing and
writing down its own piece and trying to
edit it so i'm going to read not just
about the narratives of the writer
but about
uh
its own uh
edited pieces of the writing itself
a bit of this and then the end of the
story you know so here it is
bang bang two gun shots
this is not a hollywood studio
it is just a main avenue in a burmese
city
a road peacefully used by public
servants civilians students teachers
street vendors monks and nuns
a road throbbing with noise cars
chatting blaring music
advanced
pigeons and three dogs
but these two gunshots have transformed
it
now you cannot see anybody on the avenue
instead of steps
they are just scattered centers left
behind
not even a pigeon
or a dog can be hot
let alone people's vices
it's just a far noon
but the sky is gray and dirty
already threatening rain
the sense of food and fruits from the
street vendors have vanished replaced by
smells of smoke and bullets
avoiding smoky corners
the steps are wavering
and arch to glaze backward is slowing
down progress
while looking backward the forward
moving body
is afraid it might get pierced by
something at the front
that thought hastens the steps once
again
and another piece
that wise is similar
yes i heard that
very wise not a long ago
but then i felt safe
now i feel the opposite
still right now
i will make myself face anything
if it means getting a story
so tell me what sort of story you have
my voice sounds dry
but the relief of finding i am able to
master audible speech studies my
trembling body
i
am
but then that familiar voice simply
fades away from my ears
that self from body drift backs into the
darkness
along with his horrid laughing piece
face
the big hole on his chest floats away
like a flying saucer moving into
darkness
strongly through the smell of blood
remains
as strong as ever
at this moment another wave of white
smoke rises up like a tight
it does not awkward to me to ask why an
avenue in the middle of this city has
become a channel for smoke weeds
my whole attention is focused on trying
to discern
what it is
that i can see moving towards me
in the smoke
what shapes are gradually emerging
so i'm going to read the last message
the images that are deep inside the
nozzle are gradually approaching my
chest
i can see them now
i even know what they are
but
i don't have the capacity to define them
not yet
i embrace the fear
i try to embrace the horror
even the kind of horror
that is so popular with the masses
but
ultimately
i don't have the courage to express
that kind of horror
the images are still
approaching towards
my chest
stop
please stop
i screamed in silence
and shot my eyes
enough
i've no longer wish to continue writing
this story
please respect the courage it took to
make this request and let me leave the
horror thank you
thank you so much
what i'd like to do is ask the three of
you
to just reflect on each other's passages
for a moment and then we will open it up
to an open question and answer with with
the group here
i just
i'm curious to
understand how you receive each other's
writings and some of the thoughts that
emerge as you hear each other's work
maybe i'll start with cocotet with some
reflections on the other two
uh yes um
i like her writing and sees
one of her essays
whose footfall is loudest
it's about you know
the importance of
footwear flip-flops
in the revolution since the 1988 1962
1988 2021
and
so after a
shootout military shootout people
usually flee and all is left gopi often
in the street scope could be
flip flops so she wrote about that
uh touchingly poignantly
and
she is very good at us
portraying mundane subjects and people
and you know
uh in our stories so my my question is
quite simple what were you reading i
mean uh recently and uh what what what
was your favorite uh
book in burmese or english fiction on
non-fiction yeah
yeah actually uh there are many books or
i like uh yeah so it's difficult to
mention only one so but recently um yeah
um yeah
the the same book i have read better
those can be books and i don't want to
share here it's a little bit boring so
the uh one of the book i have recently
read is you know you know um educate
educate educated which is written by
tara was over and yeah actually it's
like a memoir she wrote about
herself and her family
yeah she how she uh survived her under
the uh her discipline father here is too
religious and how she escapes from the
threats of her brothers who has a very
abusive nature and even though her
family supposed for her education uh she
uh yeah uh
yeah tell her story how she uh trying to
accept education and how she
struggled to obtain the phd however i
think her the book is more than that
because
i feel that not only about the education
she really revealing uh about her way
how
of how she deconstructs the religious
norm and gender unknowns she was shaped
at for many years i think there is
really important from her story so it's
really inspires to me yeah
and yeah i have a question for matera
too the question is that you know you've
been traveling
the length and the breath and the depth
of parma since
all of our places all over the places in
myanmar myanmar since 1989 you were
part of the nld campaign
and you were traveling a lot on the on
that campaign in 1989 right and then in
by 2019 you were also heading pan
myanmar and traveling all over the
places
so which city or town in myanmar would
be very
friendly or receptive to literary
personnel and what's the difference from
1989 to 19 2019 i mean
it's hard to say because i have been to
so many places and what i remember is
you know according to my experience you
know uh
appreciation for
writers and press are mainly from the
middle of the country you know burmese
majority because the language matters
you know they they can read
our piece very well there will be no
language barrier for them so i think i
might say the koku was one of the most
interesting
during the 1988 according to my
experience during our visit to the
upper burma they show up and then you
might notice the very beginning of the
program of the suffrage revolution is
also from bakugou and throughout these
the days
after 2012 uh literary activities
uh
has been pretty much uh
very alive in bakoku so maybe i might
say that but there are so many other uh
cities still i cannot just name it there
are so many so many uh other cities are
very uh familiar with the
uh
some cities i might say in uh aorti
division like
hindara hindara is
famous for having at least three four
literary activities
uh per year you know for the other
cities they might do only once but for
hindera it might be at least four or
five something like that you know the
the poets in hindsight are very very
strong so what's have their own choice
of the literary talk and the other group
also having their own something like
that that are so many
[Music]
cities are going on like this
[Music]
would you like to pose any questions to
matita or coco ted
uh yes
uh yeah i first of all i would like to
appreciate it to your media first
because our work of shenzhen is in
harvard uh hubbard is the first thing
that
came to her to my mind uh when i think
of literature and resistance
although
she wrote about her experience as a
political prisoner after reading her
book you know rather than being afraid
of being sent to prison i gave her the
bravery to dirt and challenge the
presidency
so her book can give her some courages
um
i'd like to honor uh his contribution
that is to engage burmese literature
with the international communities
because the country was so isolated
under the military regime for almost two
decades after 1988 revolution but now
it's happening again
that yeah you uh didn't leave us and
arrange the book like a speaking of new
shoes uh uh why not stop stop the stream
so thanks for so thanks so much for that
so my question is so somber um yeah for
a google go that um so is there any
challenge uh you ever yeah experienced
while you yeah reaching that because
i mean the uh yeah the uh the new uh
should uh will not stop the spring and
for siama mathira i'm no now you are in
jail so may i know um yeah you are
recent works yeah what are you doing
there like that yeah
uh yes uh regarding
curating and editing of picking off new
shoots will not stop the spring
yeah the first challenge was i mean
how to
collect material and in the beginning
february and march we were very much
uh
we were very
my co-editor right and myself we were
very much assisted by tanyama material
and got lots of contributions via
panyama and
and later i had to
uh scan you know the internet to do
to get quality writing and also another
challenge is diversity i would like to
include a polyphony of voices
in the collection
so we had to reach out to other resource
persons who might know you know this or
that ethnic writer and so on so that way
and we were able to include so many
different voices in the book another
challenge is to get it done in one year
because because most of the translation
was
done by me
single-handedly
even though there are several other
pieces written in english so that was a
full-time job
almost from march to september
so that was a challenge yeah
yes
yeah yeah thank you and indeed i was
about to read a small
point it's called get out of a maze
that's what i'm doing here you know i'm
thinking of writing a new novel but in
order to write that novel i need a lot
of information
so i have been
closely watching
my own country what's going on and not
just currently but also during the last
decades you know i trying to understand
i try to i also
uh here at
i try to reach out to the diaspora
population either in person or through
the the
internet i reach out to them and i try
to understand the whole picture what's
going on and i
i'm
i'm going to start my new book but still
struggling about the structure because
my my dream is quite a little big and
then the
atrocity doesn't stop it's going on so i
might decide the period
to end for my piece you know so that
that will be my uh
my future book and that would be amazed
thank you so much um i want to open up
to open q a from some of our attendees
in the audience so if you would like to
ask a question
just raise your hand using the hand
raise function
of the
zoom interface if you can't find that
just wave your hand and i'll try and see
you but you'll have to show your video
to do that one
i see a question from al lim
hi everyone thank you so much for the
wonderful presentation um and it's great
to see you i think coco ted visited
iolani west a few years ago and we had
to have lunch um at some point there was
wonderful um so it's
thank you again for um talking about the
kind of state of burmese poetry and how
you all are contributing so well um both
kind of in in myanmar and
internationally my question is about the
state of burmese poetry for like young
people is it kind of i'm wondering like
is it a big thing in universities like
how do people get into it can you just
talk a little bit more about um kind of
this the state of
burmese poetry in myanmar um both kind
of in yangon and um in other cities and
just as a comparison like in singapore
there's a big kind of like sing
singapore poetry writing month that
joshua and a few folks run and so that's
and it's being taught in schools um so
that's when people get into it whereas
in thailand it's not as big for you like
young people i feel um where it's a lot
more kind of like formal and very kind
of like
strict and rigid and and so i'm just
wondering like how do how did you know
people get into it it's great to hear
from y'all i'm just curious about how
vibrant it is um as a community thank
you
uh yes uh i can speak of poetry as you
know a curriculum in school which is
actually uh hopeless because on this
school curriculum they hardly teach any
uh
any any uh free
thinking so most of the poems are quite
rigid and
they don't eat condom reportry at all
most of the poets are dead in the long
run so that's one thing maybe that's the
reason why on the other hand there's a
vibrant
unofficial you know learning of poetry
and
other modes of literature in burma so i
i often speak of this
participatory poetry written by ordinary
people who are not necessarily poets
because our promised language also is
quite a rhyming language and if you
observing the if you're observing the
protests in in even in 2021 uh most of
the protest slogans were
were in couplets written by
participatory poets
very powerful
and very you know
in your face
against a regime so these are very
impressive
uh
lines such as
no negotiation for blood debt
and and yeah even picking off new shoes
will not stop the spring that can't come
from the
from from the
protests of parma
so anyway that's one thing and on the
other hand they are they are
uh
career poets and professional poets and
as mathias in different cities and towns
uh they are centers of you know for for
uh
how shall i see they they are literally
literary groups
poetic groups
who usually gather at uh tea shops
coffee shops and they just you know
discuss their poems and
it's like
like uh workshops in the west but they
they don't usually workshop each other's
ones but still
uh
that's in different cities they are
different centers of poor of poetry like
maui has a very vibrant
center of poetry and we lost two
poets in 2021
uprising yeah
thank you coco paul sarno you can ask a
question uh this is directed to martha
um i i read and uh found very
informative
your book called prisoner of conscience
and i understand you've written a second
book in english
i can't seem to find it on the world
catalog can you tell me please
the english title and the publisher
if you know
yes the book is called the rogue map but
it might appear under the name of my
pseudonym surat mamika the same
publisher the sikh wong publication from
chiang mai thailand
but that was that was the earlier book i
i wrote that book in english that rogue
man i wrote that book in english at that
time
because of the situation i dare not to
use my own name so i use the theorem
name surah gamika
and then yeah that that book was written
at brown and i moved to red cliff
harvard next year and i finished writing
my present memoir there in burmese but
that the translation was published
yeah as a prisoner of conscience
and how do you use how do you spell
seerah s-i-r
is a traveler
okay thank you also
if i can ask one more question i i
wondered
about how many um poets writers
uh that you know of have left uh myanmar
since the coup
uh
more than 20 more than 30 how how many
uh
it's hard to say most of them
for someone like
uh
five were arrested uh five were killed
and
uh
round about 14 where in prison
you know and then a lot has been left
but most of the
the riders and brett are resisting from
from the land from inside
they keep doing
have they
joined the
the um
um
i'm sorry i can't remember the
abbreviation but the the for the forces
that are um the fighting the hunter yes
yeah the p i'm sorry pdf or the nug have
they have they joined them
uh oh yes some some already joined yeah
some already joined the pdf and you know
the minister of the ministry of defense
of the nug himself is a poet ah
okay thank you so much jesus
thank you thank you
do we have any other questions i have
one but i don't want to keep asking the
only question i want to open it up to
others
uh eric white we have questions
hi thanks so
you know in general there's been a lot
of discussion about since the coup
there's been
greater engagement reproachment and
solidarity between the
ethnic bomb and majority populations and
the ethnic minority populations and i'm
just wondering
do we see similar
dynamics within the community of
writers of poetry and prose in the sense
of
as communities of
writers as communities of readers as
community of
commentators
um
so just wondering how the coup has
changed
uh the character actually of communities
of writers and readers inside of
myanmar and across ethnic kinds of
boundaries
right i think i i answer your question
it's hard you know that's why uh pam
yama has a plan to
have a short story uh writing workshop
with
the majority
of uh
with minorities especially
we pick
moon
chin and
kachin you know
and sean you know so that's that's
that's the problem according to our
survey in 2018
uh
there is almost
uh
very
few
from the ethnic minority becoming a
well-known writer you know
even though we do have a couple of the
um
active
communication
between
these ethnic minorities it's very hard
that's why i think the the
the ethnic literature is almost not
existing you know for example like in
kachin language there is only the
translation of the bible into ketching
language there is not much other
literature even though they do have kind
of uh
video or the
feature movie something like that but
not in literature form some so it's very
hard only
in uh shun and moon language have their
own literature
but it's not very popular it's never
been translated into burmese to reach
out to the broader audience so it's very
hard to
make a communication between the
writers written in burmese language with
the writers written in other different
languages
only we pam yama tried to reach out but
is not yet successful
because of the good we have planned to
have a short story uh training in sean
state on 22nd february and it was yeah
banned
you know
i think uh jane wants to add something
she's cheese acebot and sean even though
i'm sean i don't
go go ahead jane and while you're
talking i'm going to announce your talk
next week too
i'll put it in the chat so people
yeah thank you for um
oh am i frozen now
oh
yeah just for a second unfrozen man
yeah
chilled um yeah so the uh longest
continuously operating shan printing
press in um tanji has a huge pantheon of
shan poetry uh shan
short stories comic books um you know
that have been continuously operating
but then also in the shan liberated
territories from the 70s 80s and 90s
onwards they operated um a lead uh
linotype uh typesetting machine so the
the constant production and with the
digital age there's a whole lot out
there um but also specifically because
this revolutionary lit the ongoing civil
war and the ongoing resistance in shan
state
is in some ways
separate from the activities that have
been going on
against the um against the coup in the
burmese heartland so
there's a
political different orientation just to
summarize it very very simply but um
especially about
sean revolutionary singers some of them
will make burmese versions of the the
songs so if we want to broaden poetry to
include um rock and roll and songs
there's a tremendous amount of crossover
between shan artists and making um you
know songs that are accessible to to uh
people who don't know sean so the
language and the political
division you know can be transgressed in
really fascinating and revolutionary
ways ahead tada
i would like to add something her even
though
yeah
we are not directly engaging her ethnic
communities in the group yeah before the
cooper as much as i remembered uh we had
a poetry event two years ago uh in that
poetry
event we brought the rohingya poets to
recite their poems yeah to yeah uh yeah
uh yeah
to reveal their experience and then even
in the uh
new book uh beginning of uh new shoes uh
i think uh
some of the riders even though they are
not the ethnic people
again i mean the
net bummer
the dhs burma i think uh now some of
their ideas can cover
other ethnic experiences like the poem
of kathy i think
that can also yeah share
that poem and yeah
yeah yeah it was written by yeah can't
be yeah
her poem is really amazing and i think
that is really engaging with the
other minorities experience and
sufferings yeah
gudabian by
kathy uh it's not in the collection
analogy uh speaking of new issues will
not stop the string but a translation of
that form is published in the research
uh the channel obama research that's out
i think uh last week
so uh there's that poem there but in
picking up new shoes when i stop the
spring anthology itself there are three
uh
rohingya poets from different places cox
brazil malaysia refugee camp and canada
so we are quite happy that the
an honor that the the are contributing
those forms to
this anthology
so i wanted to ask a question for all
three of you um
about the relationship between
content and form
in um
periods of resistance
and the question that has long been on
my mind
actually
before the events in myanmar
with my work in vietnam
one of the burdens that some of my
friends who are vietnamese artists often
describe to me
is how
as artists they want to be experimental
in particularly artistic ways that are
not always driven by telling a story
about vietnam per for example um their
artistic expression transcends vietnam
ness or something like or vietnamese
ness or telling the story of quote
unquote the vietnam war or something of
that
and i've always been curious um
even with the title of this panel of
resistance and literature um
what it's like to be a writer who wants
to play with language for the sake of
language um cocotet you mentioned some
of the couplet forms or some of the
literary styles of burmese language
matida mentioned when she was younger
when she first got excited about being a
writer is just the beauty of the
language itself
sometimes that's political
and sometimes it's not sometimes it's
just artistic expression
um but cocotet you also mentioned how
they're the rigid form of certain forms
of poetry or is also linked to a kind of
repressive educational system too
and so i wondered if the three of you
could reflect just a little bit about
artistic expression
and the burden of representing
resistance and how you manage that a
little bit and how you engage with that
yes
uh i meant to see that the rigid form
itself is not to blame i mean uh when
you write in a rigid form it can lead to
you know uncertain
term
so but that i i what i meant is that the
curriculum
itself that you know that makes the yeah
the rigid form and then
of course the curriculum itself
uh is full of poems that
nationalist kind of programs and so on
did this makes
it's very problematic to become a
creative writer uh but when it comes to
writing and resistance i like to quote
the peruvian novelist mario
vargas lusa you know he said that
the mere existence of literature is a
subversive act
for instance uh burmese novelist
in the 1950s wrote a memoirs about the
stigma of syphilis
in you know
that was in the 1950s and and the book
in my opinion was a subversive act
in a time syphilis was looked down as a
curse for one's bad karma
so we can
actually write about personal
experiences personal stigma and and and
and become subversive in our own culture
in our own way
so for me the only responsibility for
writers is to write and beyond that they
should not feel any button or any
expectations from anyone
because i think resistance writing you
know just like all other creative
activities must come from
within oneself not from the outside
so a piece of writing in my opinion a
piece of writing that responds to a
groups or an individual's
political expectations is rhetoric or
propaganda
i think yeah i also
you know
i
publish a book
it's called my writing because you know
it has been pretty much contradictory
to have so many
uh people
saying oh your piece of writing is
a poem a poetry or an essay or a short
story we don't know what it is and i
said okay i also don't know what it is
because i'm not an academy you know i
just create it you know so
let's call my writing that's all you
know yay
and that one it's pretty much like
focusing on the strength of the language
itself
you know it's it's it might reflect some
uh political issue because i think the
as a writer
just we just use our own individual
way of response to the universe
so if the universe surrounding us is
pretty much political our response will
be more or less political there is no
way to escape from it that's all you
know we we just reflecting whatever we
are uh
surrounded by something like that so
even though uh
as an individual writer of course our
strength it's also not because not just
our
perspective towards something else but
also
the
the skills
the the
the aesthetic
intrinsic uh
part of the aestheticness
it's also our strength so that's
directly related to how much we can uh
play with the language
the linguist but of the our own
languages that's why i think this is
very much you know when we talk about
the freedom expression
we need to talk about the language
rights so that that's how i i see
and i i enjoy as a writer we we are the
we are the owner of our own reflection
towards the universe you know
yes or for me uh i would like to mention
about social resistance through
literature rather than the uh yeah be
resistant to the data because i think
uh i could say that uh bringing social
justice and eliminating social
inequalities it's much more difficult
than
uh there is to end the digital [ __ ] uh
because um that discriminatory
norms and values are depleted uh deeply
included in our society for many
centuries that's why when i'm trying to
um yeah write something uh uh that is to
the norms um i have to be cautious and
not to use the all walls
um yeah rapidly because uh by using this
again again i'm afraid of
strengthening or reinforcing that was
that's why i try to interchange with
other words for example in my second
novel or was my tomorrow it is about a
young woman who caused psychological
trauma since she was yen because of a
sexual violence of her cousin
as well as abandoned of her her father
so but in that case the people
surrounding her set
that she is suffering from his two years
but she hates that word
uh what i want to say in that novel
novel is the word hysteria is too
generous it is framing most people don't
think there is concern only with women
and i also want to explain how young
women are afraid of being sad history
and history history killer
so that's why they keep women they keep
their
love expressions and never declare their
love before men do so and this story
also tells about how much difficult of
me among women to divorce their husband
so in that story uh as i wanted to
construct the term history i didn't use
the word in the whole story instead uh i
tried to either change with other words
to just say that female characters
suffering suffering is just a kind of
psychological problem like others it's
not consent with female body and womb as
we used to believe in the past so here
so why my problem is whatever i'm just
all norms to discontract
i have to be cautious of using the words
if i said to you before um so if we use
the old terms uh i'm afraid that meaning
related relating to those specific wars
became repeated and it's like
reinforcing the meanings that's why i
have to be cautious about that
thank you thank you so much for this
fascinating discussion um i noticed that
we're near the end of our time so i'm
going to bring the conversation to a
close i'm going to turn off the
recording but i'll leave the zoom open
for a few minutes if anyone wants to
have any informal chat but those for
those of us who are still with us please
join me in thanking our wonderful
panelists for a great conversation